let's write 0.8 as a fraction so 0.8 the  eight right over here is in the tenths  place it is the tenths place so you  could read this as 8/10 and we can write  that literally as being equal to eight  tenths or eight over ten and now we've  already written it as a fraction and if  we want we can simplify this down both 8  and 10 share common factors they're both  divisible by two so let's divide both  the numerator and the denominator by two  we're not changing the value of the  fraction because we're dividing by both  the numerator and the denominator by the  same thing 8 divided by 2 is 4 10  divided by 2 is 5 and we're done 8 or  0.8 is the same thing as 8/10 which is  the same thing as 4/5